[Música]
todo mundo teve um professor que marcou
sua infância pensa agora quem foi esse
professor
a minha professora carla a professora
carla minha adaptação quando tinha cinco
anos
eu era um moleque que não prestava
atenção na aula era aquele aluno que não
deixava ninguém assiste à aula e ela
tomou a decisão de chamar os meus pais
na escola e chegar para isso assim ele
já ganha leve seu filho não se concentra
ele não deixa os amigos assistirem aula
mas não porque ele é um ano ruim mas é
porque ele consegue pegar os assuntos
com agilidade um pouco maior do que a
maioria dos colegas e depois ele fica
aborrecido
então a gente terá mais um desafio para
ele e ainda está sugerindo que ele faça
dois anos escolares em e essa decisão
que a professora carla tomou mudou toda
a minha vida no semestre seguinte no
comportamento melhorou completamente os
meus pais ea escola e desde então eu
venho num evoluindo e eu não consigo
mensurar o quanto que a decisão e o
cuidado que a professora carla teve
comigo o quanto que o cuidado que a
professora carla teve comigo mudou a
minha vida
23 anos se passaram e estava na reunião
com a secretária de educação de um
município do estado maravilhoso de
alagoas como de paixão e eu estava
conversando sobre a empresa na época
ainda estava com um projeto de
implementação de capacitação para
professores de ensino infantil e no meio
da reunião lembra a professora carla
falei que me perdoe
deste modo segundo o segundinho como é
que vocês cuidam atual momento de seus
professores
e como é que tal quadro de saúde deles
atualmente e ela falou informação que eu
fiquei naturalmente impressionado saída
da secretaria foi conversar com alguns
professores na mesma semana tendo para
mais duas secretarias e três meses
depois eu tenho conversado com 23
secretarias da educação e tem encontrado
que alguns desses municípios tinha um
texto de professores afastados por
doenças físicas e mentais
a cada três professores não tinham
condições físicas emocionais de entrar
em sala de aula e eu falei eu acho que a
minha empresa está no caminho errado e
eu preciso entender um pouco mais sobre
esse problema e essa busca e essa
jornada quero compartilhar com vocês
esteve 99 falou que o mal-estar docente
ele gera conseqüências como o
esgotamento ansiedade estresse depressão
eo absenteísmo as faltas é um mecanismo
que o professor tem pra conseguir cortar
a tensão acumulada e nessa procura por
tentar encontrar uma forma de mensurar o
quanto que está afetando a nossa
educação e comecei a encontrar alguns
dados como quarenta e oito mil
quatrocentos e setenta atestados médicos
dados a professores na secretaria de
educação de belo horizonte dos quais
quase 11 mil de licenças a partir de
cinco dias
trinta e cinco mil quinhentos e trinta
horas aulas mensais não ministradas por
professores afastados por doença na
secretaria de pernambuco e esse estudo
inclusive falou que a o absenteísmo
docente ele justifica os péssimos
resultados na educação pública e normais
em 2010
ele falou que esses dados não só são
reais mas como isso tem aumentado a cada
ano e quais são as consequências
práticas de sala de aula como professor
falta ou como ele tem a performance dele
comprometida
a primeira é entender que o vínculo de
aprendizagem e é diretamente ligado a um
vínculo afetivo
se o professor se afasta esse vínculo
afetivo é interrompido e por
consequência também o vínculo de
aprendizagem e já sem falar que as
relações que os professores constroem
com os alunos são o acesso mais forte a
socialização motivação e desempenho
acadêmico como é que o processo do
doente vai fazer isso com os alunos um
processo para fora de sala me é
conseguir quantificar isso ainda provou
que a cada dez dias que o professor se
ausenta o fator de aprendizagem dos
alunos é prejudicado em 3.3 por cento
que segundo esse estudo é o suficiente
para entender que isso é um problema de
política pública
do ponto de vista financeiro a
secretaria da fazenda do estado de são
paulo mostrou que 290 milhões de reais
são gastos por funcionários que falta um
trabalho por motivo de saúde dos quais
165 pontos 9 milhões são gastos
referentes à educação
nós temos um programa pedagógico
nós temos um problema financeiro ea
verdade é que o brasil não está lidando
com esse problema do tamanho que ele
está e quando eu comecei a trocar a bola
então problema existe um problema real
mas como é que esses professores vão se
afastando primeiro e doenças
osteomusculares relacionadas ao trabalho
é um nome bonito
só que na verdade dores
dores que vão desde o que comprometem a
performance dos professores chegando a
incapacitar eles completamente chega a
ser insuportável da aula porque estão
com dor no pescoço dor na coluna no
cotovelo punho e isso é uma gigante que
se junta com os problemas de voz
boa parte dos afastamentos vem por
distúrbios de voz e fatores associados
nesse estudo aqui por exemplo eles
encontraram uma correlação entre
indivíduos professores diz fônicos e
doenças emocionais como ansiedade
depressão e quando ele vai falar sobre
as doenças emocionais na verdade elas
são fruto de algo muito maior
um texto dos professores estão com
depressão e isso se acentua
principalmente no ensino público e no
ensino de base onde esses números eles
são realmente amplificado e esse é o
cenário do brasil em alagoas é assim
dados da secretaria de educação da bahia
também eles são consistentes no sudeste
não é tão diferente assim e nós temos um
problema generalizado
o brasil precisa cuidar dos seus
professores isso é óbvio
só que tem uma frase muito interessante
é que não me digas suas prioridades
me diga onde você investe seu tempo e
seu dinheiro e eu te direi isso as
prioridades dos vários fóruns que eu fui
da educação é de técnico em gestão
pública e inovação em gestão pública que
fala sobre espaço meio de metodologias
ativas métodos de avaliação só que ainda
não entendeu que quem vai entregar esta
inovação toda é uma pessoa que está
depressiva e está com a doença
incapacitante na coluna que o brasil
investe muita grana isso não se traduz
em resultados na educação porque está
olhando para esse problema pelo lado
errado
o professor júlio furtado muito
pertinente escreveu a matéria neste mês
mostrando dados interessantes primeiro
que essa idéia fez um levantamento onde
15% há 15 anos atrás alerta dez anos
atrás o percentual de jovens que queriam
ser professores era de 8% na pesquisa
recente viu que agora isso é 2.4 por
cento ou seja os nossos jovens não
querem ser professores e outro dado
importante que é o levantamento do mec
que se deu conta que cerca de 35% dos
professores em atividades 700 mil
professores estarão em idade de se
aposentar em 2022
jovens que não querem ser professores
nossos mais experientes que estão aí na
esquina de se aposentar e os que ficam
estão doentes por ano entre começa a
resolver um problema desse tamanho
qual é o caminho não existe resposta
certa mas me deparei com esse documento
que foi o início da minha jornada de
começar a tentar fazer alguma coisa por
esse problema
a carta do tauá foi um documento que
saiu da primeira conferência
internacional das nações sobre promoção
de saúde
eles identificaram que capacitação
seriam norte a gente capacitar as
pessoas para que elas possam atingir seu
potencial de saúde através da
capacitação que a gente consegue
promover saúde e qualidade de vida então
já entendi poxa eu vou fazer algo por
esse problema capacitando esses
professores capacitando que o que não
faltam são boas iniciativas
existe um problema de saúde vocal que
provaram que os 100 professores por
cento dos professores que começaram com
mais de 35 thomas relacionados à voz
apenas 45 por cento desses professores
continuaram com a mesma quantidade de
sintomas não capacitar para usar melhor
a voz na área de doenças osteomusculares
capacitar para que as lesões sejam
evitadas através de um programa de
prevenção ele precisa ser capacitado
para conseguir manter a sua integridade
física e também no componente físico a
que esse estudo mostrou que no
componente nutrição e atividade física
tem sido demonstradas como de maior
freqüência em todas as regiões do brasil
eu preciso capacitar os professores para
que eles possam se nutre melhor para ele
sair do sedentarismo e eu preciso
capacitar os professores para que eles
tenham uma melhor saúde emocional
esse projeto piloto de meditação na
escola americana provou que os sintomas
de bonaldi da pressão de professores
foram amenizadas por uma prática diária
de meditação e quando os professores
levavam isso pra sala de aula eles
tinham a maior concentração entre os
alunos eo menor perto um percentual de
dispersão entre esses estudantes são as
pistas estão aí os dados estão aí para
ajudar a gente e 3 informações fizeram
eu tomar a decisão de criar um projeto e
essas transformações são manter os
professores e fornecer ferramentas para
o auto cuidado pode se traduzir em maior
eficácia o seu papel em sala de aula
embaixo tem que a maioria das
intervenções escolares
estão projetadas para estudantes
a gente não olha o professor como um
final como uma pessoa a ser beneficiada
políticas públicas em que olhe como
atravessador para chegar até o estudante
isso não tem funcionado muito bem e
ainda falta um programa que seja
implementado de forma sistemática e
falei é isso é isso que eu tenho que
fazer é por aí que eu vou e eu creio que
a vida 360° uma capacitação que pudesse
ajudar os professores a prevenir a
atingir seu potencial de saúde previne
problemas de voz problemas de doenças
osteomusculares e promover a saúde
emocional ea a orientação inicial era
professora de dinheiro tem que fazer
aquecimento vocal
antes de ir pra escola profissional eva
você tem que fazer meditação em casa
antes da aula
só que professam o bicho tão generoso
que começou a acontecer quero fazer
nunca não tenho tempo eu posso fazer
isso em sala de aula e hoje na escola
miguel matias na escola virgem dos
pobres quando ela começa a dar aos
alunos já sabem que têm que fazer
exercícios de aquecimento vocal junto
com a professora
aqui a professora eva também citando
todos os dias com os alunos do ensino
infantil eu tive na sala da professora
eva e foi assim que também gritando e
joaquim só eu
aí falei o que é que mudou aí ele falou
comportamento foi que massa porque a lei
a bárbara era muito brava nunca mais
imagina isso larga escala sendo feito em
todas as escolas
não estou falando aqui da mega
tecnologia não estão falando aquele algo
absurdo que ninguém pode fazer são
coisas simples promover o auto cuidado
porque a profissão bicho generoso eu
falei para eles fazerem pra eles eles
automaticamente transbordaram em si para
a sala de aula é isso que faz comenta
cuidado a gente transborda cuidado
quando a gente sofre nesse caso a gente
transborda descaso e essa espera
a agência tem professores que não têm
tido mais que vive crise de garganta
outros professores que falaram que
reconquistaram o prazer que está em sala
de aula e as reflexões que me deixa eu
queria compartilhar com vocês são os
seguintes o brasil não tem problema de
falta de investimento em educação ele
tem um problema de eficiência a gente
aumentou de forma agressiva o valor por
aluno investido mas isso não se traduz
em resultados e especialistas
baseado na experiência de países mais
bem sucedidos que nosso fala que o
próximo governo tem que investir
fortemente no professor
segunda a quem está olhando pela
educação pelo prisma dos alunos e talvez
a gente precisa trazer o professor para
o centro das discussões da educação o
professor protagonista da educação tal
qual os alunos olhar para a solução dos
nossos problemas sob a luz dos cuidados
com o docente pode ser um dos caminhos
para atingir melhores resultados que os
investimentos ele já existem eles só
precisam ter um outro spectrum outras
conversas eu tenho na conferência óleo
muito cuidado você falar de compra de
obras equipamentos e um tabu grande que
tem projetos como eu não sei tantas
outras iniciativas bacanas que tem por
aí afora é que politicamente falando da
muito mais retorno investir em obras
equipamentos do que investir em gente a
gente precisa mostrar para os gestores
que o caminho está investindo em pessoas
e isso ele perpassa o público e também
da privada mas nem precisa começar a
trazer levar isso para a nossa sociedade
e ela a educação por esse lado outro
existe um ponto cego da nossa educação o
processo não foi informado ele foi lá
pra dar aula de geografia e de pequena
liga com 20 moleque na escola pública
que sofrem violência de todas as formas
que você imagina
ele não foi preparado para lidar com
essa violência entre ser capacitado para
isso ea outra que eu sempre gosto
plástico o elástico da história quando
você começa a puxar ele
eu acho que há muita pressão e aguenta
desgaste só que esse apadrinhamento que
eu entendo que esse elástico tem 10 o
estágio de desgaste até estourar e poder
entender que de 400 professores
eu tenho aqui 200 que tem nível 5 de
desgaste na área das dores
de prevenção ainda cabe a esses
professores só que não sei ao certo o
que não existem dados que me permitam
entender com mais profundidade se
projetar perto de estourar o sevilla no
começo do processo
precisamos entender esse problema mais a
fundo e o que você tem a ver com isso
eu criei o servidor 360 graus
a empresa de políticas públicas projetos
de lei produtos/serviços trabalho
voluntário qualquer pessoa pode você
nutricionista para atender três
professores da escola pública de graça
no seu consultório por mês você
estatístico pode ajudar a entender
melhor o problema se você toca violão
leva música pra sala dos professores não
sei que vai fazer mas eu sei entender
que você pode ter uma parte independente
que você seja na solução desse problema
a gente precisa abraçar seus
profissionais
a gente precisa acolher melhor porque
como é cuidar melhor dos professores
deve cuidar melhor das nossas crianças a
quem precisa olhar para as soluções dos
nossos problemas da educação sob a luz
dos cuidados com os professores porque
quando lembra a professora carla fala
assim imagina imagina o cuidado que você
gostaria
imagina o cuidado que você gostaria que
o professor dos seus filhos tivessem com
eles a professora carla ela ela foi
determinante não com a etapa super
importante da educação eu fico
imaginando se tivesse continuado a me
sentir um desajustado uma pessoa que não
se enquadrava que danos que poderia ter
autoestima que danos que poderia ter
a gente precisa realmente cuidar dos
nossos cuidadores aí precisa acolher
capacitar esses profissionais porque se
não fosse a professora carla talvez eu
não estivesse aqui hoje com vocês muito
obrigado
[Música]